There are two ways to add classes.
>From the previous screen, you can
just click the check box over here,
then click Register.
I'm going to go ahead and register for
Software Architecture and Design.
That will take you to
the Schedule screen.
Here we'll see your Current Schedule.
You'll see here the class for
which you just registered.
>> However, you might want to do
some advanced planning instead.
Remember that CRN column
on the previous screen?
You can use this to register too.
Before your Registration window opens,
write down the CRN numbers of the
classes for which you want to register.
So in this case,
I would write down 90097,
which is the CRN number for
Software Architecture and Design.
Back on the Registration screen,
I'm going to click Add or Drop Classes.
This will take me back to the Schedule
screen that you saw earlier.
At the bottom, you can enter
the CRN numbers for the classes for
which you want to register.
So I would enter 90097, and
then click Submit Changes.
Just like before, now you'll see
that class in your Current Schedule.
That way, when registration opens,
you can come directly to this screen and
just enter the CRN numbers for the
classes for which you want to register.
>> Note that this process
might not be successful.
If I try to register for more hours
than I'm allowed, for example,
I'll see an error message.
So after registering, make sure that
the class appears in your schedule.
If not, look for an error.